[موسيقى]
تصادف ان انا طبعا في سني انا حاليا انا
مؤرخ والصحفي فعشت هذه الفتره يعني هذه
الفتره
الامير تشارلز خطا فيها ديانا وتزوجوا قبل
الحادث وحتى اييي في الفتره اللي هو اصبح
فيها امير ويلز وكان لسه شاب صغير في
نهايه
الستينات فانا عشت هذه الفتره صحفي حتى
تفاجئ بهذه الاحداث اصلا احداث مختلفه
مختلفه يعني همم مثلا رؤساء الوزراء
السابقين اللي هم كانوا بيلتقوا بجلاله
الملك الله يرحمها انت عارف انا رئيس
وزراء يلتقي بالملكه بعد الظهر يوم
الثلاثاء اللي هو اجتماع مجلس الوزراء ههه
كلهم قالوا هذه احداث مختلفه لها اساس لها
من الوقت
[موسيقى]
لكن المشكله نحن امام الان اجيال بتاخد
معلوماتها من التلفزيون من الاعمال
الدراميه
اللي بياخذ من الكتب وانا الوثائق وبعدين
التاريخ بالمناسبه هو كائن حي التاريخ
بعد 20 سنه او 30 سنه كما هو والاجيال
بتاخذه
[موسيقى]
المنتجه والكاتب امام معضلتين عندما عندما
يتعامل مع جانب تاريخي او مع عمل تاريخي
اجراميا
المعضله الاولى اذا اخذه كما هو اصبح عمل
وثائقي وليس درامي
واذا اعمل فيه خياله بشكل او باخر اصبح
فيهم يطلع مغلقات واصبح مظلل
[موسيقى]